I think it's a good choice to work in
the I.T sector because the potential for
growth is just tremendous I'm working as
an I.T business and Cloud consultant at
one of the top I.T companies in Germany
which for me is dream come true hi there
I'm Yuri roganski I live in Frankfurt
Germany and I have done two courses from
Simply the master and data sites and
master and Cloud architect I have been
working in different engineering jobs
since graduated from University in 2016
but in 2019 I felt I wanted to do
something better
felt like it is one of those fields with
endless potential
but to make that switch I had to get
upskilled and learn the latest
Technologies and advancements for that I
chose simplival as soon as I completed
my courses I started applying for jobs
and soon enough I got into devops
project at AWS at one of the best it
Consulting companies in Germany even
though I was new to the I.T and I.T
security field I got a decent salary
Improvement and early 2022 I got an
Azure Solutions architect expert and an
AWS Solutions architect associate
certification but without the materials
provided by simply that I couldn't have
I constantly referred to it while
studying and I'm sure simply around
certifications will help me a lot in the
future since I was new to the topics
they helped me a lot at the beginning of
the course
I really enjoy hiking water sports
traveling and playing chess
so while handling my daily activities my
hobbies and family time I used to take
out evening sessions and dedicated
weekends for learning
so yeah if someone asks me was it worth
it
my answer without even thinking
would be yes definitely it's a
no-brainer